[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con una de las
cosas que nos ha permitido la pandemia
es darnos cuenta del ritmo vertiginoso
que tenía nuestra vida y que estaba
dejando consecuencias negativas tanto en
el medio ambiente como en nuestra salud
por lo mismo muchas ciudades se han
planteado un cambio en la forma de
funcionar una de ellas es parís y el
cerebro detrás de ese cambio es el
profesor franco colombiano carlos moreno
que tal carlos usted acuñó el concepto
de la ciudad de los 15 minutos una
ciudad donde nuestra vida cotidiana
transcurre a máximo 15 minutos a pie de
nuestros hogares cuéntenos cómo se le
ocurre esta idea y en qué consiste
efectivamente este concepto es el
resultado de un trabajo de investigación
con mis equipos en la sorbona basado en
el hecho de que para luchar por el
cambio climático era necesario atacar de
raíz el problema y el principal
contribuyente son las ciudades y las
movilidades dentro de las ciudades
pensamos que en este caso es mejor
reducir las movilidad es vivir más en la
proximidad en los barrios localmente
profesor tomemos como ejemplo la ciudad
de parís
17 barrios 2 millones de habitantes un
poco más una periferia que depende
completamente del centro de
aproximadamente 12 millones como se
cambia una ciudad así tan grande en este
otro esquema por dónde comenzar qué
plazos se pueden considerar lo que
queremos hoy en día es revitalizar la
proximidad para que en cada barrio me
extremos seis cosas vivir trabajar hacer
nuestras compras cuidarnos en salud
física y mental acceder a la educación
agricultura y tener un lugares de
esparcimiento el proyecto de parís es
traer en la proximidad esas seis cosas
para que cualquiera de los parisinos
podamos acceder a ellas simplemente a
pie o en bicicleta es un proyecto sobre
seis años pero ya hemos hecho cosas muy
concretas que cosas concretas las
escuelas por ejemplo están cerradas
desde tiempos inmemoriales los fines de
semana porque no se utilizan son muchos
metros cuadrados que están disponibles
ahora con la ciudad de los 15 minutos
las escuelas abren los fines de semana
para que hayan actividades de diferente
índole tenemos igualmente proyectos de
cultura al aire libre dentro de las
ciudades que hemos igualmente propuesto
para que los artistas hagan espectáculo
vivo en los barrios tenemos un
presupuesto participativo 800 millones
de euros únicamente para proyectos de
barrio igualmente tenemos igualmente el
comercio de proximidad para luchar
contra las plataformas y tenemos una
empresa de la ciudad ciento por ciento
ciudad que compra metros cuadrados y los
alquila con un precio por debajo del
precio digamos del mercado masa para
evitar el mercado especulativo y por eso
llegamos con comercios de proximidad
profesor y económicamente estas ciudades
son autosuficientes
ninguna de estas ciudades es
autosuficiente porque la autosuficiencia
con una ciudad tan densa parís es la
sexta ciudad en densidad en el mundo
pero lo que queremos es crear una nueva
relación entre parís y los territorios
donde se necesita
queremos crear lo que llamamos una
alianza de territorios para ir con
circuitos cortos a traer abastecimientos
directamente de los productores a los
consumidores hemos darle importancia a
los circuitos de biológicos queremos
igualmente ofrecer lugares de
agricultura urbana no solamente para
autos es para estar los suficientes que
no es posible pero crea una sociabilidad
tenemos un programa muy grande de 100
hectáreas en parís dedicada a la
agricultura urbana con un proyecto que
se llama caficultura que responde usted
a los que lo llaman utópico hace cinco
años me decían que era una utopía porque
el concepto era bonito pero nunca se
podría trabajar cerca de su casa
simplemente hay que un mapa del
mundo hoy en día y ver que parís lo está
haciendo que igualmente en la red
mundial de ciudades el c40 a la que
pertenecen ciudades de chile santiago
entre otras
buenos aires- bogotá
en rio sao paulo ese cuento adoptó como
estrategia saliendo del cob y de la
ciudad de los 15 minutos puedes mirar
ahora la ciudad emiliano con su alcalde
la ciudad de los 15 minutos y tomar las
campañas electorales que hay en día hoy
en diferentes partes del mundo ayer en
new york
en diferentes ciudades como cincinnati
el sacramento es una situación que se
produce en el mundo entero o sea que las
utopías fue hace cinco años
muchas gracias carlos moreno y ustedes
continúen con la programación habitual
de france 24
[Música]